house Speaker Kevin McCarthy has just
announced that in the upcoming spending
fight any and all spending cuts to
Social Security and Medicare are quote
completely off the table now this
promise poses a problem since 46 percent
of federal spending comes from Social
Security Medicare and related programs
which means that if no one wants to
touch those entitlements the federal
government would have to reduce 85
percent of all other spending military
education energy servicing the debt all
of it
in order to deal with the deficit which
is to say it becomes impossible
Republicans used to pull their hair out
over this issue of entitlement reform
some 20 years ago back when the debt to
GDP ratio was less than 60 percent
we came pretty close to actually
reforming entitlements a dozen or so
years ago when debt to GDP was about 90
percent
but now we've got a debt that is 123
percent of GDP
in other words we are just not going to
pay it back or ever meaningfully pay it
down especially since we accumulated all
that debt back when interest rates were
around zero before they shot up in
recent months making debt much more
expensive to service and pay off
but it doesn't really matter because the
U.S is the top dog around the world
so as long as we remain dominant and our
dollar remains trustworthy the U.S can
keep on spending money we don't have
with pretty much no consequences
we are in a new phase of our nation's
history and everybody knows it and
nobody is even pretending otherwise
anymore not even the Republicans not
even the conservatives we no longer need
to worry as much about how to pay off
tens of trillions of dollars of debt
but we've only traded that problem for a
tougher one
how do we Remain the world's most
powerful Empire forever I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Walter sobchak
who says I have to click two agreements
to watch some Wonder Mike spit some sick
truths to my ears thank goodness I can
just watch WAP without any warning
because of its pure wholesomeness this
is pretty weird yesterday a number of
you called my attention to it that there
was not one
but actually there were two warnings
that you had to click on before you
could watch my episode my episode on
the news of the day my episode on the
officer involved killing in Memphis my
office my my episode on the Paul Pelosi
home invasion my episode on I don't know
the 2024 race apparently all that was a
little too much
my episode on Pfizer or maybe that was
what triggered it I don't know it's kind
of weird though you can go watch any
manner of smut porn violent videos
bizarre lies you can watch that on
YouTube no problem but you want to watch
the Michael Knowles show
oh that's free you're not allowed to do
that that's too bad even though all
we're trying to do on this show is give
you a little bit of of an antidote to
some of the poison that we see in our
culture and when you need an antidote
and when you need it fast even a supply
chains break down you got to check out
Jace medical right now go to
jacemedical.com use promo code Knowles
if the past couple of years has taught
you anything it is that in a crisis like
a global pandemic or a natural disaster
even the basics can be hard to come by
that is why you've got to be prepared
for anything Jace medical is here to
help this is a brand new sponsor to the
show that I'm really really excited
about Jace medical helps you get a
long-term supply of prescription
medication their mission is to empower
you to be better medically prepared a
great way to start preparing is with the
Jace case it's a pack of five different
courses of antibiotics that you can use
to treat a whole host of bacterial
illnesses including UTIs respiratory
infections sinusitis skin infections and
more
all you've got to do is fill out a
simple online form and in some cases
jump on a quick call with one of their
board certified Physicians from there
you can ask your physician treatment
related questions on an ongoing basis
I'm going to put this really simply for
you if China invades Taiwan the U.S
supply chain is going to be cut off okay
if any number of crises occur in the
world you're going to be cut off make
sure that you've got the medication that
you need all right we now in the Knowles
household have peace of mind because of
Jay's case I want you to be prepared for
anything go to jacemedical.com enter
code Knowles at checkout for a discount
on your order that is chasemedical.com
promo code Knowles
good news is we don't even need to
pretend to care about paying down our
debt and dealing with our deficits
anymore bad news is we need to remain
the dominant Empire or else it's all
going to collapse
you you only don't need to worry about
your debt when you're the top dog
when you're not the top dog though then
then consequences can come quite
suddenly
very very gradually over time and then
quite suddenly so the question is who's
going to run the Empire that's what a
lot of people are asking right now
Donald Trump wants to run the empire
Joe Biden wants to run the Empire and
increasingly it would appear that Ron
DeSantis wants to run the empire
DeSantis doing a great job in Florida
he's got a book coming out one of these
politician like books that sets the
stage for a presidential campaign he's
got a ton of support he's surging in the
polls all over the country
president Trump does not like this
president Trump says
that Rhonda Santos
is a globalist
he's specifically referring to the Club
for Growth here and
and he's attacking the club for growth
and he's attacking Ron DeSantis and he's
attacking the candidates associated with
both these guys he says the Club for
Growth is a globalist group that I've
been taking to the cleaners for years we
worked together for a period but they
couldn't get away from China Europe Asia
and Parts Unknown
they know I won't play that game I am
America First all the way that's the
only way we will make America great
again Ron de sanctimonious who I made
governor in both the primary and the
general is also a globalist and so are
his donors Jeb low energy Bush was next
to him last week check passed
so so now you can tell there's a little
bit of a logical issue in this attack on
Rhonda santis which is he says
Rhonda sanctimonious who I made governor
who I who I got through both the primary
and the general is a globalist so you
say well if he's
if he's a good Governor then you can you
should take credit for him if he's a bad
governor and he's a globalist you
probably don't want to take credit for
him but it doesn't matter Trump is
throwing the kitchen sink at Ron
DeSantis and I think it's a smart move
I know that a lot of Republicans are
very upset certainly people who are
already signed up on the DeSantis train
they're very upset at Trump for this
even a lot of trump supporters say why
man come on the race isn't for or the
election rather isn't for another couple
of years almost two years why are you
going after DeSantis he's one of the
most popular Republicans in the country
he has to go after DeSantis because
DeSantis has a lot of momentum on his
side
and he's gaining a lot of support and so
if Trump wants to beat DeSantis he's got
to attack DeSantis do I think that this
is the the most persuasive attack I've
ever read in my life uh no not exactly I
don't I don't think that this is
changing a whole lot of Minds on Rhonda
santis but it's the opening Salvo
in what Trump is preparing to be a long
primary campaign against Ron DeSantis
now what even some people who like Trump
are saying is this is a bad strategy
because you're attacking Ron DeSantis on
an area where he is very strong and you
are very weak
stop going after Rhonda Santa
specifically you don't even see it too
too much in in this particular attack
but you've seen it more broadly in in
Trump's salvos against Ron DeSantis
he'll say well DeSantis shut down
Florida DeSantis wasn't that great on
kovid DeSantis wasn't he's not all the
things he says that he is
and they're saying this is really dumb
you should attack DeSantis where he's
weak not where he's strong DeSantis is
really strong on covid Trump is
relatively weaker on code why would
this is not just craziness okay this is
not just Trump shooting from the hip and
following a gut impulse that's wrong
there is a good argument for this
strategy this is the Karl Rove strategy
so most people just intuitively believe
you should attack your opponent where
they are weak and you should you should
uh not not attack your opponent in an
area where you yourself are weak Rove
said no it's the opposite attack your
opponent's strengths you don't need to
attack their weaknesses their weaknesses
are manifest attack your opponent's
strengths turn your opponent's strengths
into a problem for them this was most
clearly done in 2004 when Bush was
running against John Kerry the Iraq War
was a big issue in the 2004 race John
Kerry was a military veteran a decorated
one even though John Kerry's Behavior
after the war was shameful and George
Bush did not really have all that much
military service so the the common sense
said don't attack John Kerry and the
military but that's what the Republicans
did specifically the Swift boat Veterans
for truth attacked Kerry said his
service was a bunch of BS he was a
grandstand or a Showboat or a ribbon
collector and it it worked the strategy
did work so you might hate Trump you
might love Trump he might love to Santa
you might hate DeSantis I don't care my
thought though is
one Trump strategy makes a lot of sense
desantis's strategy is very smart too
DeSantis is just not responding to any
of this
he's going to continue to govern in
Florida that's exactly what he should be
doing
and for the people who say well why do
they have to attack each other
because this is politics
why does Trump have to do this because
this is politics
well it shouldn't be like this well it
is like this it is always like this this
is what politics is if jockeying for
power
annoys you rather than amuses you
why are you paying so much attention to
politics
go watch baseball
I don't know although baseball can be
very intense too go I don't know go to
an art gallery if this if watching
ambitious men jockey to gain power and
attack one another in the process drives
you crazy and makes your blood boil then
stop stop being involved in politics
you're you're not going to like it
that's all politics is
we like to think that those men once
they attain power will govern in a just
way for the common good and do all these
higher-minded things but the actual
process of attaining power is this this
is it this is all that it is
DeSantis is
doing exactly what he should be doing
Trump is also doing exactly what he
should be doing and we'll see how the
primary process shakes out speaking of
political jobs a story came out a few
days ago we didn't have time to get to
it before out of the RNC the Republican
National Committee Ronald McDaniel was
reelected there was a race that came on
between Ronald McDaniel who's run the
GOP for a dozen years and Harmony Dylan
who was a favorite of some more
conservative people probably than
support Ronald McDaniel though it broke
down it was a little bit confusing
because Trump backed McDaniel DeSantis
backed Harvey Dylan so you've got
conservatives in both camps you've got
some squishes in both camps too McDaniel
won as I knew would happen
I I did have some people come up to me
behind the scenes ask me what I thought
I did I don't think I even maybe talked
about this on the air so I don't know
that I get full Nostradamus credit for
this prediction but I did predict it and
people said ah Michael we've got to back
our meet we're gonna throw all of our
support behind her I mean I said well
you're free to do that I like Harmony
Dylan very much I said but if you if you
wanted me to place a bet right now my
bet is Ronald McDaniel holds on
these people looked at me shocked they
said oh what what are you talking about
all the support is for hermit Dylan I
said no people on Twitter like Harmony
Dylan
and I'm sure many people at the RNC
privately like our meet Dylan too but
Rana McDaniel will hold on to power
if you're surprised by the re-election
of Heart of Ronald McDaniel 111 votes to
Harmony it's 53 and then Mike Lindell
got four votes if you're surprised by
that you haven't been paying terribly
close attention to the Republican Party
the the way that the party committees
work the way that elections work broadly
does not correspond
often if ever at all to what people in
certain political bubbles are talking
about on Twitter that's not how it works
some people are very very upset about
this they say no we can't that's
terrible Rana didn't do a good job now
she's still running things this is
terrible I don't really care who runs
the RNC I like Rana I like our meat I
like Mike Lindell for that matter I
don't I don't really care all that much
it's not a great job to have it involves
a lot of really granular kinds of
decisions and and most importantly of
all any significant Improvement to to
the Republican party or to U.S politics
is going to come from outside of the
Party Committee I'm not looking to the
RNC to solve our political problems
that's not what the committee was built
for that's not what the committee does I
don't think that's what the committee
can do Donald Trump didn't win in 2016
by convincing the RNC to support him
Donald Trump engaged in a hostile
takeover of the Republican party and
then the RNC sort of got on board so
okay whoever runs the committee fine
whatever the the real significant
Improvement it ain't coming from some
Party Committee in Washington D.C
speaking of employment
a Google executive was fired for not
being inclusive enough
because this Google executive you see he
engaged in a terrible crime he favored
good employees over underperforming
employees
his Google exec was fairly high ranking
he was allegedly sexually harassed by
his boss
and then fired for failing to be
inclusive according to a lawsuit filed
in New York federal court he fired Ryan
olehan as managing director of food
beverage and restaurants telling him it
was because he was not inclusive enough
what did he do
Google's employee investigations team
explained that this guy had shown
favoritism toward High performers which
it considered non-inclusive and
commented on employees walking pace and
hustle
which it considered ableist
if you've ever worked in a restaurant
I've worked in restaurants you know it's
a kind of intense environment especially
if you're working in the kitchen
and but waiters too you got to move you
got to move fast so if you say hey move
quickly let's go put a little hop in
your step that's very ableist
we're and and the real issue was
apparently this guy uh didn't
discriminate against white people enough
in February of 2022 Adam Stewart who's
VP of Google's consumer government
entertainment division told olahan that
there were quote obviously too many
white guys in the division
and then in July
Stewart in the company's HR department
quote encouraged olahan to terminate the
employment of a male member of his team
and replace him with a female hire
because it wasn't inclusive enough
unless you fire the white guys and and
unless you you uh discriminate against
white people and against men you're not
being inclusive enough
and why why is this
olahan says he's just picking the best
people for the job he's not he doesn't
care about race he doesn't care about
sex even he's just hiring the best
people for the job and he's favoring
High performers and promoting them
Google says yeah maybe you are but
that's a problem
if the argument is
that non-whites
cannot compete on Merit
then the only solution
is conscious active discrimination
against whites
if the argument is that women can't
compete with men on the Merit in these
jobs then the only solution is active
discrimination against men
that is the only solution
if you see this in major lawsuits right
now
that will determine the fate of
affirmative action quote unquote in
college
what's affirmative action in college
it's saying that
students of certain racial backgrounds
cannot compete against students of other
racial backgrounds on the Merit and so
you've got to describe actively
discriminate against the students of
the more successful racial backgrounds
but what does this mean in practice you
know the lawsuit never would have gone
anywhere if this were simply about
discriminating against white people
you're not allowed to complain about
that you're not allowed to object to
that at all in our culture the reason
that it's gone anywhere with the
universities is because Asians got
lumped in with the white people too that
was one of the real flaws of the
affirmative action regime if they had
just limited it to white people it
wouldn't matter it is legal and
culturally accepted and frankly
culturally encouraged to attack white
people and slander white people and
discriminate against them in our culture
the mistake they made was lumping in
Asians and so the the lawsuits in this
regard have have said wait a second why
are you discriminating against Asians in
many cases who come from from difficult
backgrounds immigrants don't have a lot
of money didn't have a lot of
opportunities why are you docking their
points on the SAT or why are you docking
their points in the overall metric to
admit students to college
and then giving an artificial boost to
Black and Hispanic students
why are you why on Earth would you do
that and no one can really give an
answer
but that's but it has to be that way
that this is the logic of it
either people are going to compete on
the Merit
or you are going to actively
discriminate against people and it's
interesting that this this lawsuit is
coming up right now as the Supreme Court
we are waiting for them to strike down
affirmative action or to uphold
affirmative action that is going to have
a lot to say not just about this case of
a Google executive
who was not inclusive enough because he
was not exclusive enough he was not
inclusive enough because he didn't fire
enough white guys
it's not only going to have something to
say about the fate of that case it's
going to have something to say about the
future of the country
where are do we have a caste system or
not
do we have favored groups or not and
this and therefore disfavored groups or
not speaking of the job market
Maryland lawmakers
are proposing increasing the weekend by
50 percent
that's right they're proposing a four
day work week let this legislation would
provide state tax credits as high as
three quarters of a million dollars per
year for businesses that reduce at least
30 employees from a 40 hour work week to
a 32 hour work week without a reduction
in pay or benefits
now of course the businesses might be
able to do this in the short term
because they're just getting the pay and
benefits from the government then they
can just pass that along
why do people want a four-day work week
well one because it we all want to just
sit on the couch an extra day that
sounds very pleasant or even spend more
time with their families or you know
catch up on reading or fix up the house
but the argument from the business side
is that the four day work week framework
uh it gives employees a better work-life
balance and actually makes them more
productive some 45 workers cite
lackluster flexibility when discussing
why they left previous jobs roughly 48
percent mentioned Child Care
difficulties according to a survey from
Pew research and this international
study
concluded that revenues increased eight
percent for companies involved with the
experiment so they reduced the work week
by one day Revenue increases by eight
percent now this is just one study
perhaps there there will be others to
back this up but I I can totally
empathize not only sympathize but
empathize with the workers who say look
I don't have enough flexibility I'm not
seeing my kids enough this is really
tough especially now that we have an
economy where both parents are expected
to work it's very very difficult in this
economy to raise a family on a single
income
so Daddy's got to go work Mommy's got to
go work and then who's taking care of
the kids then you've got to try to
arrange do I get it maybe I can get an
extra half day off here every so often
and then but really what you got to do
is just take all the money we're making
at the widget Factory and go pay some
other woman to raise our kids we don't
really want to do that can we go on
vacation can we do we have any
flexibility at all
so
the Maryland lawmakers are proposing
this radical idea of the four day work
week
I have a more radical idea
I I know there you're going to hear the
arch capitalist libertarian type people
who say no we shouldn't reduce the work
week at all we should work seven days a
week and we should let the market sort
it all out no I'm not I'm not arguing
that
I'm all for reducing the work week for
some people
what if follow me here we reduce
the work week of mothers dramatically
what if we reduce it down to like
nothing down to from five days not just
four days maybe to like zero to one days
and then we balance that I know we're
going to balance in the economy we
balance that out by having the fathers
and the husbands work even harder
so you've got a situate where you've got
the moms can stay home and raise the
kids and you reduce the number of people
in the labor force because now you're
removing up to half of the labor force
and so therefore the wages are going to
increase for the other half that remains
in the labor force and in so doing
you're much more likely to have a
country in which a family can support
itself on a single income and then the
children get to see Mommy and they just
they don't just need Mommy to go work
for some Mr McGillicuddy at the widget
Factory so that Mommy can put her money
into a bank account and then Daddy can
pay some other woman to raise the kids
what if then what if you actually had in
that case
a complementarity between the roles in
the family and you had the children
spending time with their mothers and the
father going out and bringing home the
bacon wouldn't that be so radical and
weird that's such a crazy idea I wonder
maybe I'll call up the Maryland
lawmakers because they're on to
something here
these all these people doing all these
studies in the lab coats and they're on
to something here
but maybe
our answer is I mean we've got we've got
more evidence for this than than even
for the four day work week because this
is the way the world worked
until very very recently really until
the world wars the second world war when
the men were all overseas women started
to enter into the labor force and then
companies really enjoyed women entering
the labor force because contrary to the
gender pay Gap or whatever nonsense you
hear about that the companies love to
hire women because the more people you
have in the labor force the more it
drives down the cost of Labor and this
has been a big Boon to GDP this has been
a big Boon to to corporations this has
been disastrous though for the American
family which is why workers are
complaining about all these problems
right now but you can fix these problems
you don't need to reinvent the wheel you
can go back to a more traditional way
of living
speaking of men and women
Dylan Mulvaney
I covered Dylan Mulvaney not on this
show exactly but I did a long video that
ended up going pretty viral on YouTube
about who Dylan Mulvaney is how this
this obscure Broadway performer ended up
pretending to become a woman and then
sitting down interviewing the president
of the United States in a very short
period of time
and I gave my take on Mulvaney
that he's not just a troll
he's not just
making fun of transgenderism
even though he's prancing around and
Performing this ridiculous caricature of
a woman
saying you know I'm it's my first day as
a woman I've cried three times today oh
which is
frankly somewhat accurate part of his
performance is quite a caricature but
women do cry a lot okay and it's just in
my in my experience I've known many
women in my life but but a lot of his
performance is an over-the-top
caricature and so some people thought oh
he's just a troll
he's just making fun of the whole thing
no I don't my argument was that this is
an actor who's been trained in the
modern style of acting who is who is
indulging the worst
uh and and most dangerous impulses of
that style of acting which actually goes
back even before the group theater even
before the Strasbourg method it goes
back to the Russian Moscow Art Theater
director stanislavski and it goes back
to Freud and again so it it has uh
Ripple effects in our culture far beyond
the theater and it would seem that I am
right because Dylan Mulvaney has
undergone a facial feminization surgery
to carve up his face to make him look
marginally more like a woman
so Dylan Mulvaney comes out in
this bizarre kind of ballet costume
not looking much more like a woman
his face looks a bit like Caitlyn Jenner
because I assume sir Bruce Jenner who
after he revealed himself as Caitlyn
because I assume they all
follow the same guidelines but he
doesn't
he doesn't look like
that's a wrap on face reveal oh my gosh
hi I missed you you know I have a flair
for The Dramatics but it's so good right
I'm so happy and it's still me it's just
a little bit softer of immersion and I
just hope that all trans and non-binary
people can get the gender affirming
resources that they need because this is
life-changing and sometimes life-saving
so thank you so much for supporting me
and we've got so much to catch up on I
love you
[Music]
this was Dylan Mulvaney's face reveal
whatever it is he's not Faking It people
don't get the bones in their face
chopped up because they're Faking It
people don't get other things chopped
off I don't know if he's done that yet
or not don't really want to know either
they don't do that because they're
Faking It
this is a real delusion and it's it goes
a lot deeper than
just some people following some deviant
desires this is exploding as a
phenomenon it is a social contagion it
might be because they're turning the
freaking frogs gay with chemicals in the
water more likely though I think it's
it's a social phenomenon and it's
because all the rest of us are indulging
it with a straight face if if we as a
society just said nope this is nuts you
have no right to do any of this you have
no right to call yourself a woman you if
you do if you refer to yourself as she
and her we are going to ostracize you
for that and we're going to we're there
will be consequences in your
professional and educational life and
we're just not going to tolerate that at
all if we if we were a little less Live
and Let Live man
then Dylan Mulvaney would live a much
better life
because the consequences of our Live and
Let Live who knows man maybe your good
is my bad maybe your yuck is my young
maybe your man is my woman you know what
I'm saying man r r
the consequences of that radical
skepticism
or now that this man is chopping up his
face and engaging even more destructive
behavior that is not going to end
well
speaking of transgenderism major big
first
really really big first
um the first openly transgender figure
skater
has just appeared at the European figure
skating championships in espu Finland
this is
a Finnish skater who's
an older man
dressed up as a woman
skating around not
not the most gracefully but he's sort of
skating and then he falls down and then
he falls on the ice and
he can't stand up
and so then
The Finnish people with the flag come
out and try to help him stand up
and then
and the craziest part of this whole
display
is that we're not allowed to acknowledge
it I mean on this show we do but in the
culture you're not if you if you're
sitting there
in that audience I
you can't hear it on any of the clips
that I've seen and I'm sure you couldn't
hear it in the in the audience
you're not allowed to say oh this is
weird this is funny this is obviously
absurd no we all have to just sit there
and pretend oh yes she's so beautiful
these poor little girls who are on the
track teams with all the confused men
are on the Penn swimming team with that
Hulk of a man who took all their
trophies and then what do the girls have
to do
on camera they have to smile they have
to plaster his mom they say this is a
really great she is so beautiful we love
being on her team and then privately of
course when they're speaking to
journalists and they can remain
anonymous they say this is terrible we
don't want some guy getting naked in our
locker room and taking her trophies and
taking her scholarships and this is
deeply unjust but then when the cameras
come out they say aha well this is you
are beautiful Caitlyn and Dylan though I
don't know what Dylan's new lady name is
going to be I guess Dylan's kind of
androgynous you are a beautiful Nina
Maria finish you're the greatest skater
I've ever seen you're a regular Tanya
Harding
uh
in totalitarian countries
one of the things that we Marvel at
is that the people are forced to perform
lies all the time when Kim Jong-il died
and you had major parades all throughout
North Korea to honor the death of the
great leader
you saw those cameras in all these North
Koreans
perhaps some were moved seriously by
sympathy I kind of doubt a lot of it
though for many of them they were
performing it because there were guns
pointed at them and they they knew that
if they didn't cry enough over the death
of dear leader
they could be tortured they could be
killed
their family could be killed
everybody has to lie this is true in
Stalin's Russia
and Soviet Union this is true in China
and this is now true
in the West
we are forced to lie too because our
government is increasingly totalitarian
it's a total state
it comprises everything
if you in your HR meeting
don't affirm that some hulking hairy
dude wearing a dress and stilettos and
with lipsticks smeared on his face is
actually a beautiful woman you could be
fired and you probably will be fired and
once you're fired for that you you're
gonna have a hard time getting more
employment
and you're going to be a pariah in your
Society
it was so terrible when North Korea does
that terrible and so the good thing we
live in America the land of the free and
the home of totalitarian delusion every
day more and more so
but love is love right love is love you
do you
trans women are women
everybody's uh whatever they want to be
okay if love is love then I've got a
question about a story that just came
out
story out of ABC News
a couple of hosts for Good Morning
America three
uh we're just fired because they had an
affair
Amy robach and TJ Holmes I've never
watched this show I didn't know there
was such a thing as Good Morning America
3 but they were hosts of it and they
just got fired because they were both
married
and then they had a consensual Affair
and then this came to light and and it's
not as though one person accused the
other of sexual harassment or anything
like that
they're both married
but they had a consensual Affair and uh
now they're now they're canned
why is that wrong
I know why it's wrong
because marriage is an indissoluble bond
between a husband and a wife
for the good of the spouses and the sake
of the generation and education of
children I know I know it's wrong
because spouses take a vow before God
and before the political Community to to
remain with one another through thick
and thin good times and bad sickness and
health
and and that's wrong to break but
that's not what the modern culture
believes the modern culture believes
that marriage is nothing but a kind of
meaningless sheet of paper and we can
leave our spouses for whatever reason we
want and that's called a no-fault
divorce and there's nothing wrong with
polyamory polygamy whatever there's
nothing wrong with any of these
Arrangements
Love Is Love
Love Is Love that's the whole argument
for redefining marriage is that the
affection between two men and the
affection between two women is the same
as marriage the affection and then
institution that that desire leads
toward
uh
in the institution of marriage that's
all the same okay well if love is love
if all shades of love and affection are
exactly the same then why don't they get
to have their there was consensual
yeah it wasn't so nice to their spouses
but so what we don't we don't really
give much
Credence to marriage vows anymore
why is this wrong
because if if we know that this is wrong
then what we're really saying is that TJ
Holmes and Amy Robuck should have
repressed their romantic desire for each
other they should have denied the love
that they felt for one another they
should have pushed it way way deep down
because they had other obligations
because the moral order demanded more of
them then that they follow their love
for one another to its physical
conclusion
but if that's the case then
and isn't that then isn't that just the
case then isn't that just how it is and
shouldn't we apply that to all other
all sorts of other manner of love as
well
no a little bit confusing
Love Is Love except for Amy Amy robach
and TJ Holmes they don't get to have
their love but
all sorts of other people all sorts of
weird polyamorous people with three guys
and two women and a billy goat that's
fine that's love that's wonderful how
dare you judge that but
Amy roback and TJ Holmes get fired for a
consensual Affair that's really weird
it's also really weird because Amy
robach I actually had forgotten this
until producer Danny reminded me of this
today
Amy robach
you may have heard of her because she
was caught on a hidden mic
discussing how she wanted to pursue the
Jeffrey Epstein story at ABC and the
producers and the executives shut her
down and she knew that Jeffrey Epstein
was a real story
when she knew that this involved a lot
of corruption she wanted to run the
story and the higher ups at the network
said nope don't talk about that
so that adds another layer to this where
I think huh it's so so weird how people
who transgress the
powerful liberal Elites people people
who contradict them or who get on the
wrong side of them
they end up in a sex scandal and their
career goes away and then they bury them
not all that long after they raise these
problems really weird not obviously what
they did is terribly wrong and they
should repent of it and go to confession
and try to make up with their spouses
and try to keep their families together
there's a lot more to this story though
seems like there's a lot more to this
story both as a cultural matter
and even as a particular political
matter
with regard to Mr Epstein who may or
probably did not kill himself
then meets the eye listen up folks
we have been running a massive 40 off
sale for annual memberships it's ending
soon do not miss the chance to celebrate
one of the greatest moments in Daily
wire history with one of the greatest
offers that is 40 off annual memberships
with code do not comply one year ago we
sued the government over its tyrannical
vaccine mandate we won celebrate this
Victory by joining the winning team and
remember this is your last chance to get
40 off your new annual membership at
dailywire.com subscribe cln soon so head
to dailywire.com subscribe today today
is Tuesday
today has taken your calls Tuesday
that that is my new favorite segment
because we have finally gotten
technology from the 1970s at the daily
wire and I can take your calls right now
so
let's turn to
uh Luca in North Carolina Luca you were
on the air
hi Michael so I'm in college and I'm
taking this really great class called
how to rule the world with this like one
in a million like young genius like very
conservative professor and um we read
um xenophon account of Cyrus's life and
you know on all accounts I think Cyrus
was a was a very good leader except for
some you know things near the end of his
Reign but my question is for you
um the desire to like rule the world
that ambitious like drive that a lot of
people and like necessarily leaders have
do you think that that's like a
fundamentally unchristian desire
no I don't think that it's necessarily
an unchristian desire I think it can be
a perfectly Christian desire within its
just limits I mean as with all
government there's a good version and a
bad version so I mentioned this on the
show yesterday polybius's theory of of
anacyclosis the cycle of regimes that
you have three good versions of
government monarchy aristocracy and
democracy and then you've got their
corrupted bad versions which is tyranny
oligarchy and MOB rule respectively
and what's the difference the difference
is that the good versions of government
are versions in which the rulers rule
for the common good
so you can have a monarch who rules for
the common good there have been plenty
of good monarchs throughout history you
can have an aristocracy that rules for
the common good and you can have
democracies that rule for the common
good but in the corrupted versions The
rulers be they a single individual a
group of people or the people at large
are are the ones who rule not for the
common good but for their own selfish
interests so you know you think of this
in the American context that warning
that the Republic is going to collapse
when people realize that they can bribe
the people with their own money and and
then demagogues rise up and this creates
a big problem uh so we need government
government is given to us by God for our
own good
we need government to execute Justice
and to preserve law order and peace
which are good things and the Civil
Authority has ultimately the sword to
execute punishment even capital
punishment and does not bear that sword
in vain
this is a Fallen World the prince of
this world is the devil so we we don't
want to think that we can save ourselves
and create a kind of paradise on Earth
through civil government that is not
going to happen
and if if that is the impulse to take
over the world then then that's not very
good but if if we want to rule the world
uh
and thereby it maintains some degree of
peace and Justice and allow people to
flourish then that can be a wonderful
thing I I know that this this is going
to sound a little jarring to people who
have been raised on the kind of
conservative mottos that government is
always bad and no government is best and
we should never pursue politics
whatsoever all the shallow libertarian
quasi-anarchist maxims that have become
popular in the last 30 or so years that
that's not true we shouldn't just focus
on procedure to the exclusion of
substance we shouldn't just focus on
form to the exclusion of substance the
question is not is it good to wield
political power or not wield political
power the question is
what are you wielding the political
power in service of really really good
question let's turn to Matthew from
Louisiana Matthew you're on the air
hey Michael I had a question about a
recent post from Thomas Massey on
Twitter regarding project Veritas and we
always kind of discuss and debate what
is the Public Square and what should be
allowed in it and I guess unless project
Veritas and uncovering the idea that
Pfizer May potentially be mutating
viruses was somehow illegally gained I'm
curious your thoughts on using the terms
of service if you will on something like
YouTube to potentially restrict the
uploading of otherwise legal videos when
that's kind of their business is
uploading videos and just your thoughts
on you know how we may be able to
challenge things and and truly open up
the Public Square for debate and
discussion so appreciate the thoughts
really good question I actually had my
own video yesterday censored by YouTube
so you know I put this show out on it
goes out on terrestrial radio all over
the country go goes out on the podcast
feed goes out on daily wire plus which
is where we have the most leeway and
really we can say whatever we want but
sometimes on YouTube in particular and
Facebook they will censor us they'll put
warnings up and I had two warnings on my
video yesterday I don't really know why
I did talk about project Veritas and
Pfizer so it might have had something to
do with that the short answer to your
question is Google and it's subsidiary
YouTube
they have no right to censor this
information they have no right as a
private company well if you don't if you
don't like it build your own YouTube
nope I don't buy that for one second if
I don't like it I'm going to wield my
political power that I have as a citizen
in a self-governing republic to stop
these people from from taking important
matters of public interest out of the
Public Square Google controls ninety
percent of the flow of information
around the internet if you control the
public squares particularly in a
republic you control the whole political
order and I as a citizen have something
to say about that and and I I want to
bring the full force of the state down
to stop them from doing it there's a
there's a further issue with Google
and YouTube which is that they are kind
of arms of the government yes they're
kind of private companies but there was
a lot of government money that went into
building Google they work very very
closely with the government and so I
don't think that they're protected as
some kind of private company I think
when they violate our free speech in
many cases that is a violation of the
First Amendment you saw this especially
in the Twitter files where it came to
light thanks to Elon Musk that the FBI
and the doj were pressuring Twitter to
censor information
okay now it's no longer just Twitter is
a private Corporation censoring
information and you don't have no
recourse to First Amendment protections
now it's the government using Twitter as
a proxy and that's very often what
happens and I suspect that's what's
happening here with Google I say bring
the full weight of the state down on
them
let's see let's turn to Kyle in North
Carolina hello Kyle
hello
um my question is
um how do you balance completely
avoiding near occasions of sin and the
chance to improve in your own virtue
great question really good question
there's a good book on this topic by Dom
Lorenzo scoopoly it's a book that's
about 500 years old called the spiritual
combat and the answer is that it depends
on the sin and it depends on you so your
question is
if I I think that the premise here is
that if you want to improve in virtue
then you need to be able to look your
sin in the face very often and be able
to resist it so if you want to get over
your alcohol problem it's not enough to
just throw out all the alcohol in your
home you also need to be able to be in a
restaurant where there is alcohol and
not feel so tempted that you go you got
to go grab it okay that's true
of most sins and the way to deal with
that is prudently and and in in such a
way that okay maybe if you're a you're a
booze hound you're you've got all the
booze out of your house for now and you
haven't had a drink in months and then
now you're at a party and there's a bar
on the other side of the room you're not
going to go near the bar but you sit on
all the way on the other side of the
room and then maybe you can be in a
place where there's more alcohol and
people and more people are drinking and
you can do that gradually and you've got
to test your own limits there is one sin
that this is not true of according to
Dom Lorenzo scoopley and the spiritual
combat that would be the the sin of lust
that's the one where spiritual writers
have written about this for many many
eons you just have to run you're not
going to confront it okay only Christ
can confront the Antichrist period uh
with with certain sins and temptations
we can tolerate being around them a
little bit more depending on your
susceptibility to them with lust because
sex is so Central to human nature when
you are finding yourself tempted by lust
you just have to run you have to run in
the opposite direction so there's no
there's no world in which you get to the
point where you can uh I don't know go
to a strip club or something there you
go or you're going to walk around that
red light district in that town you're
in or you're gonna go to if you know if
we're not talking about that extreme
where you go to a bars on on women's
night at the bar and you're surrounded
by these single women that's you're
you're not going to get to a place where
you're going to improve in virtue by
resisting that you're you're more likely
to destroy your life as Andrew claven
points out every man has two drinks and
a wink away from destroying his own life
so I would flee from that fast as you
can okay we got more calls that I want
to get to and then we got we got
important stories that Mr Davey says I
haven't covered we're gonna do that on
the member block if you are not a daily
wire member what is wrong with you head
on over dailywire.com Knowles use promo
code Knowles at checkout yet two months
free on all annual plans and I will get
to chat with you in the member block
[Music]
foreign